doctor-prescribed twitter man pisces 5k
okay do coffee Roger how's your chef
ready to dive dive dive over ha ha ha ha
Silvia last dived here nearly 4 decades
ago using a special diving suit called
Jim there is a new tool in the sea it
moves with the ponderous rhythms of a
mechanical monster her question can
scientists used the Jim suit for dives
beyond a thousand feet waiting
if successful she will be the first
woman to walk the seafloor beyond 1000
feet Silvia is looking for signs of
change well you're up near the surface
it's kind of like blue but as you go
down
you see the pretty shades of blue and
the blue gets darker and darker then it
get pitch-black it's really black and
you're dropping there's no Indian light
[Music]
it's like a different world
actually our world is different this is
normal new life comes to light an
unknown Coral Chris doesn't even know
what species this thing is this is the
only place to really seen at this spot
I've seen something life lesson when I
was just a turd it was like a magic
carpet oh my goodness
beautiful except it's better than any
old carpet it's alive my applying so you
never stopped looking out the window
she's just excited to see things that
she hadn't seen it so on
the ranges eight something he's trapped
from those little plants under his
that's unbelievable he did he got one of
those is all I'm mixing just watch these
two days he Paula Mexia because the way
took a kid with fresh eyes to notice
something that has been happening all
along because after Finn pointed it out
we looked and we saw it happening all
around us low-yield I swam at all did
you see that yeah
[Music]